one of them is literally would you
rather be aist or
[Laughter]
KIRO that's so funny Would You Rather
become the MC of redo Aila and do what
he did or become the Black Swordsman AKA
K this guy literally thinks he's like
man I know I know the boys hate KIRO but
how is how is sort on online got such a
bad rap where people think this is like
a legit question it's just an easy
punching B
you get you get like intense trauma your
entire life then become a hideous
horrible human being or become a
protagonist of sort online or just have
a nice cushy Life playing video games
get married and uh have have girls for
over you I I know I don't know man I
don't [__] with Kyo normally but I'm
definitely [__] with him in this
instance would you rather be right or be
happy well I can tell you for one thing
guys trash taste is one of them I it's
not right I feel like a lot of people
would say happy but I think a lot of
people secretly would rather be
miserable and be right all the time well
it depends who you're asking right if
you're being British isn't it uh Yes
actually I think actually I would rather
be right all the time what do you I
[__] knew you what you read
it and because it would get to the point
where I'm always right and then everyone
would [__] be like dude he's always
right he's [__] [__] sucks be yeah
then you wouldn't be happy yeah but you
wouldn't be happy it would just be
miserable I think I would get happiness
eventually from being right all the time
but here's here's here's the question I
always like struggle with would you
rather be ignorant and happy or
knowledgeable and miserable you know
because ignorant and happy ignorant and
happy because I I like I I get this I I
get this sometimes whenever there's no
punishment for being ignorant you know
what I mean like you just you don't know
you're ignorant you're just happy that's
I think I'd rather be ignorant and happy
yeah the smart person I I think I think
at some point we made the conscious
choice to stop being ignorant and yeah
but there is the saying ignorance is
bliss getting getting like learning and
getting knowledge and expanding is is
addictive but also
dangerous yeah because okay you know
there there's a moment in our childhood
I guess where we were [__] ignorant
but you know we were happy about that a
lot of the times and I feel like as an
adult I have happiness were we ignorant
or were we just unknowledgeable cuz I
think there's a difference well we're
just [__] idiots cuz we're kids were
kid ignorant that's the same thing right
no ignorant means no what what is the
definition of ignorant ignorant is like
you're doing it right
now well no not being ignorant because I
want to know so I know I'm wrong
ignorant is like you are completely like
to lack a large amount of awareness on a
subject this lacking knowledge or
awareness in general uneducated or
unsophisticated unsophisticated God damn
God damn Google you didn't have to go in
that hard
you don't think about maybe like what
else there is out there maybe you're
content with like your very like like
you know like Clos minded not CL not CL
minded that's like conscious ignorance
you know if if you consciously block off
the rest of the world then you're
conciously choosing to be ignorant right
but there is there is a point where we
made the guess I guess like the
conscious decision to go outside our to
go outside of let's say our little town
or our bubble our world and we chose to
become more knowledgeable about the
world um did it make me happier I don't
know if it did honestly sometimes I see
a lot of people in like the small towns
that we came from and I'm like damn
they're just [__] happy man they're
they're just happy living their life and
just having you know living their life
in that bubble and I you know I'm I'm
not saying this as a bad thing because
I'm [__] jealous of them at they
content right yeah they content's the
wrong word I mean some of them are
content some of them are genuinely just
like some of some of them are genuinely
just happy living the lives that they
have and that's completely fine and I
think to myself huh there was a point in
my life in my childhood when I was that
happy when I didn't like when I was just
happy with the things I had there was a
point in my lives where I you know this
this is the best kind of like uh
allegory no that's not the right word uh
this is the best analogy analogy that's
that's what I was looking for that was a
point in my lives when I was just happy
[__] eating chicken wings at
McDonald's for my mom every day of my
life I did not I did not crave Japanese
food I did not crave Japanese food I did
not crave all of these other kinds of
like foods and then you know suddenly I
go out I try nandos for the first time
and I'm like now I crave Nando yeah yeah
yeah you have like a you can like when
you try all these new things and explore
you almost then you're like okay but I I
need to keep satisfying all the things
that I've done yeah exactly right and I
never would have [__] eaten Thai food
yeah stayed in well or I would have had
it once like oh wow look at this
Oriental Cuisine ooh look at this ooh
and then I think to myself am I happier
now or was I happier back then being
ignorant of the larger world you know
and so like I guess my question
depressing isn't it my question is would
you go back to that kind of ignorance
and just like blank like forget all your
memories [__] no and uh just I'd be on
the same path regardless I'd always find
a way to [__] myself over want more I
can't change the future can't change I
am gone yeah if you could go back in
time and be like actually you just stay
in your little Welsh town I would maybe
I would maybe go back for like a week
but I wouldn't want to relive the whole
thing again yeah you know like just like
just purely based on Nostalgia it would
be nice to go back to that childish
mentality of the world is just like this
brand new thing and there's so much to
learn and there's so much you don't know
and like you know cuz I've always had
the the enjoyment of going out there and
learning something you being like oh wow
I never knew about this thing this is
cool I'm a dumb idiot I don't know
anything about anything but like would I
want to then relive my entire
adolescence again going through that
maybe not I'm pretty happy with how much
knowledge I have and the lack of
knowledge I have that I'm still yet to
learn so yeah I do it for a limited time
do you think Luffy wants to find one
piece
I don't even know if he knows anything
to be honest like what do you think is
going to happen after he finds it you
just
like it's not what I was hoping
for what if it's all about knowing it's
out there and the journey to find it
rather than the actual ending of finding
it yourself you know becomes a
dictator yeah he goes back to GARP and
he's like you're all right Granddad I I
should have joined the Marines you know
now now was whack now everything that
Roger did is uh he's going to become a
mar it makes so much more sense now that
you think about it yeah he's going to
inspire the next generation of pirates
by becoming a master and then we get one
piece two two piece two piece two piece
yeah would you rather have St exist in
real life or nen exist in real life n
nen you think so yeah I think cuz
there's more of a variety of nen and
there's so much more you can do with nen
than absolutely not there's no normal
variety of n yeah [__] stands are
like insane like stands are insane but n
is more moldable you know what I mean
like n you can kind of do whatever your
will is yeah stands you're Prett
obviously it's a skill issue that you
need to be borned with but so is Stan
so you know but I feel like St get so
like eerily specific yeah also you can't
impress a non-stand user by having a
stand but you can impress a non- n user
with n g would be like my stand ability
is that every time the clock strikes 11
I can suck back in the fart if I have a
fart and if I do it causes a minor
explosion somewhere in a fourth world
country Conor's ability would be like
every time I sit down for the toilet
even if it doesn't have a bedet I can
still summon the bed stand my stand
wipes my ass for me my stand bed my ass
so it's clean my stand is just ask jees
just yeah I I just think like with just
how the nen system is based I think
there's more of a variety and there's
more of a what's the word uh there's
more of a an opportunity to have like
way caller powers in nen than you can
withstand so although they are very
[__] similar this this question is
[__] weird V asks would you rather be
the main character in a monster themed
hentai or a side character in isai where
you know you will die so basically have
sex with a monster or die I think I'd
rather die yeah I think I'd rather die
oh I was going to say
moner well depend depends on the
monster different I've seen anime's
definition of monster the ugliest
[__] orc alive kill me look but if
we're talking like you know daily lives
of monster
mck exactly exactly what what kind of
what kind of monsters are we talking
about are we talking about say for like
humans it's like the the most grossest
human beings politicians uh you know
you'd have sex with them you like no I'm
good I'll
[Music]
die I will take death so what you're
asking is do you want to take a chance
in having the worst [__] experience
possible uh so it's basically like it
also really depends am I top or
bottom why does that depend what wait
wait wait what what I think that's I
think that's a valid question am I top
or am I bottom it's a monster uh it's
probably top tell tell me why it matters
because if I'm going to [__] a monster
I'd rather [__] a monster than be [__]
by a
monster I'm just being real with Joel I
would rather [__] a monster in the butt
than get butt [__] by a monster is it
a deal breaker kind of okay what if the
monst is a top are you you killing
yourself I'm killing myself I I was just
like the imagine the one criter the one
criteria between you and [__] l
regarding yourself is like am I top or
bottom I'm bottom all right it's like if
like morbius was like you get the blue
or the red pill like am I top in the
blue
yeah what I want to be top bro okay so
so it doesn't matter if you could like
be [__] the most hideous monster of
all time it's like some the crafti and
monster that guchi if I do it from the
back I can't see his face you
know my God can we put any of this in I
don't know